in this video we're gonna think about
why we have seasons on earth like summer
and fall and winter and spring
now one theory that some folks might
have is maybe it's due to the distance
between the earth and the sun we know
that the earth orbits the sun the sun is
where the great majority of the heat and
the energy on the surface of the earth
comes from
and maybe it's the case that there's
certain times of year when we are
further from the sun and there's other
times of year when we are closer to the
sun
well this doesn't actually hold up to
why we have seasons because first of all
when the northern hemisphere the top
half of earth has winter the bottom
hemisphere has summer and vice versa so
it can't just be to the distance of the
whole planet it also turns out that when
earth is furthest from the sun is in
july which is in the middle of summer in
the northern hemisphere and when we are
closest to the sun is actually in
january which we know tends to be our
colder season in the northern hemisphere
so distance to the sun does not hold up
as to why we have seasons
the real reason
why we have seasons is because of
earth's axial tilt i guess you could say
that or its rotational tilt now this
picture shows that tilt but before we go
into it i'd like to remind folks that
this is nowhere near drawn at scale
the actual sun has a diameter over a
hundred times that of earth a million
earths can fit in the sun and the actual
distance between the earth and the sun
is over a hundred times the diameter
between the sun and earth but going back
to tilt and you can see that here in
this picture
earth's north pole does not point
straight up from the plane of earth's
orbit around the sun what do i mean by
the plane of earth's orbit around the
sun
this red
circle that you see or this ellipse that
you see if you imagine that being on a
surface of a table or plane that would
be our orbital plane and we can see that
the north pole does not go straight up
from that and the south pole does not go
straight down that actually we're
looking at an angle of about
23.5 degrees and that's the reason why
we have the seasons
to understand why that is the case let's
imagine earth when the northern
hemisphere is most pointed towards the
sun which happens in late june and so
let me draw the equator to help us
visualize this a little bit and let's
compare that to when the northern
hemisphere is most pointed away from the
sun which happens in late december and
so i will draw the equator again to help
us
to help us visualize this and let's pick
a similar point in the northern
hemisphere so let's pick a point that's
a little bit above the equator so let's
say that point and a comparable point
in this scenario is going to be
right over here it's about that same
distance above the equator
notice in late june in the northern
hemisphere the sun is almost directly
above this white point that we're seeing
here while in this scenario the sun is
at an angle the surface of the earth is
more like this so the sun's rays are
coming at an angle
and if you think about it think about
the scenario the difference between when
the sun is directly bearing down on
something versus when it is coming at an
angle let's say this is a side view of
two surfaces and the surface on the
right has twice the surface area you can
see the side view has twice the length
so the surface area if you were to see
it in 3d
would be twice the surface area of what
we have on the left here but if you have
the same amount of sun coming from the
same direction so here let me just draw
three sun rays here this is just
indicative and let me draw three
sun rays here
notice you have the same amount of
energy but here you're hitting twice the
surface area so the amount of energy per
unit surface area is going to be half as
much in this scenario where the sun is
coming at an angle versus this scenario
where the sunlight is coming more
directly on top of that point and
wherever you go in the northern
hemisphere the angle is less direct in
the winter than it is in the summer now
there's also some effects on the amount
of daylight you get for example in the
summer when the northern hemisphere is
most tilted towards the earth in the
north pole you're going to have constant
daylight and the south pole you're going
to have constant nighttime and then the
opposite happens when the northern
hemisphere is pointed away
and then when we think about spring and
autumn in either hemisphere you can see
that the angle of earth's rotation does
not change from that 23.5 degrees but in
spring and autumn the northern
hemisphere is not pointed to or away
from the sun it's kind of just pointed
to the side so in these two points
comparable points on the northern or
southern hemisphere are seeing similar
angles of the actual sunlight